the
protests that quickly turned into riots
uh that began in portland after the
death of george floyd in the end of may
uh have uh receded just a little bit
since the election um as as if it was a
temper tantrum about trump at some level
but not completely at all which then
suggests what
what is it what what are you people
doing so active vandalism continued in
portland
um even though the weather now here is
um
you know quite chilly quite wet you know
quite
not conducive to hanging out in a street
party
um here's a story from the oregonian
from a couple of days ago
um or actually just two days ago police
arrest three after protest related
vandalism in southeast portland they of
course uh
went after the local chain of
um excellent i think supermarkets new
seasons
and say that they were protesting quote
colonialism
gentrification and capitalism this was
wednesday night in specific
prelude to thanksgiving because that is
what they see the holiday
as um thank you zach
um they're never gonna run out of
excuses
of course right so those those words
could
i should have and i did not predict that
they would have been the words used in
this case colonization capitalism and
gentrification
that thanksgiving represents according
to some process
protester that talked to the author of
that oregonian article
um but the fact that they aren't going
to run
out of reasons that can fit any
absolutely any scenario
does not answer the question of why the
adults in charge continue to let it
happen
what what could possibly be going on
here
and you know this i i don't want to be
talking about this again
but you be weak in the face of a tantrum
and then
be assured that the tantrums are going
to get worse in the future
of course they will if you've ever dealt
with a small child or especially if
you've seen
some other parent failing to deal with
the tantrums of their children it's
easier if it's not your own
and see them get worse and worse and
worse the kid get less
and less and less both controllable and
productive and happy
in the face of a parent who is is
weak-willed and makes
fake threats etc and there's just
there's
no good resolution down that road this
is about power
it's about power we should be listening
to them when they say that everything is
about power
and take it back from them they have
demonstrated they're neither mature nor
wise enough to have power why are we
giving it to them
all right so we are giving it to them
i believe because you know we keep
running into the same
structure in stories that are so
different from each other
that we don't recognize it as the same
right we have a conflict between
the individual level and the
higher level of analysis in other words
governance is the manifestation of our
collective interests or at least it's
supposed to be
but it's staffed by individuals who have
interests that make them
uh manipulable and can cause you to get
them to do
things that are actually bad for all of
us right so
the politician may understand in fact
that the right thing to do is to deal
with the protest but they may not want
to pay the price of the person who makes
that call
right we have an okay but the election
just happened
oh i agree if they were they've got a
little time here
and um yeah go on well
i guess my point would be i would agree
that if you were going to see
a shift in which the collective
well-being
took precedence over the individual
survival of the politician you would
expect it to be right after the election
when
they have the longest period of time for
memory to fade before the next election
so the fact that we're not seeing it now
ought to scare the hell out of us
because it means
uh even under the best of circumstances
these people can't find their balls
and you know make the right call it's
also true that i am certain i do not
have the data to back this up but i am
certain that a majority of portlanders
do not want this garbage to continue
this this is this is not what most
people want
lots of people quietly will say i can't
believe this is continuing to happen
in fact you know i interacting without
people knowing what my positions are not
being familiar with the podcast etc
um have had no one say you know good on
them
keep it up and everyone who has brought
it up say
this needs to stop i don't know where
our leadership is
well i i agree now i do think there's a
sampling
bias there sure is like i said you know
these are people who
don't know who i am i think but
obviously there's you know
there are circles in which i travel
right and you know just
by virtue of what one does in the world
at the moment the people you're most
likely to interact with are people who
you know have businesses and you know
things like that although um you know
retail clerks i try to engage
um the people not just who are you know
who own the small businesses that are
still managing to stay afloat
um that we can manage to to to go to at
this point but
anyone who's ringing up a purchase who
presumably is you know not a small
business owner for the most part right
but even you know i i hate to say this
but even those people
you know have jobs they're working
towards something and so they're not
hell-bent on destruction so you know it
it's a it's not but that's the thing do
you think a majority of portlanders
don't have jobs and are held been on
destruction no you don't
no i don't but but here's what i do
think is that the game theory that
causes a mayor to do
things that any rational analysis would
say are insane from the point of view of
what a mayor is supposed to accomplish
those same phenomena structure
the interactions of the public because
the public of portland
is involved in signaling its
agreement that there is something dire
about
our you know racial dynamics that this
is having important
impacts on uh you know people's
well-being and you know to that
extent i agree but um but
the point is that active signaling and
in fact the
the positive feedback as people are
one-upping each other and signaling
just how irate they are about these
dynamics and just how interested they
are
in a solution is causing those at the
higher level at the level of actual
governance
to be paralyzed because they think they
are facing
um and you know an angry population
that is demanding these things and you
know that is of course fueled by the
fact
that those people who are breaking the
law are
actively punishing anybody who tries to
say hey look this is unreasonable
right those people if you say this is
unreasonable you're a fascist you're a
nazi you're all of these things
so what that means is artifact from the
point of view of the power structure
there is an artificial deficit of
disagreement over what is to happen next
and
a you know a false consensus about
do more do it now and here's the stuff
you know defund abolish all of these
things
although um i think it was the first
action of the city council
after the recent election um which
had an important vote that went a
different way because mingus maps won
this this seat from
incumbent chloe utley
voted against uh city council member
hardisty's desire to
defund by 18 million dollars the
portland police bureau um so that
that it seemed like that was going to go
through which would have been
i wish i knew what fraction of the
police budget that was and i don't
remember
it seemed like that was going to go
through and that would have been a
devastating blow
to police and policing in portland but
it did not go through so you know again
there are these
little things the election happened uh
we got
an apparent rejection of the chaos on
the streets of portland
and yet still as of two three nights ago
there is still black block marauding on
the streets doing
you know vandalism and and
why like why who who wants to live
in a society like that yeah it's nobody
it's not a society
um and you know one hopeful note i did
talk to somebody this week who i'm going
to interview
on the podcast um who has been close in
with these circles
and it sounds like the
that you know we've argued that there
were two forces that came together
this summer that you had a black lives
matter force motivated by
george floyd's death and you had a long
standing arc
why did i just lose the word anarchist
thread here in the pacific northwest and
that these things became
one well and you had cove at exhaustion
well you had lots of contributing
factors
you had two factions okay yes marched
together and
were involved in some kind of dynamic
that was big
and they seemed to be going their
separate ways and
to the extent that what is going on in
portland and in some other
major cities is actually about anarchism
maybe the public is going to start to
wake up that just because they save
black lives matter before
they bust in your storefront is you know
doesn't make this a coherent action that
yeah these people if you talk to them
they really do have this nonsense idea
that the
the route to the better world is just to
tear it all down and that we will be
better off
without it and you know they're nuts and
frankly i think it's a lot easier to
recognize the insanity of their position
than it is to understand what's wrong
with black lives matter because of
course
you know the black lives matter slogan
is right right and so it covers a lot
you